Je fume du crack depuis que j'ai 15 ans.
Je fume des joints, je bois de l'alcool,
je prends du valium...
Je fais n'importe quoi.
Je vois mes amis
en train de crever de faim ici,
en train de tomber
à cause d'avoir fumé du crack toute la journée.
On n'a même pas de sanitaires propres !
À l'entrée, c'est dégueulasse.
On n'a pas d'eau potable !
Où est l'aide ?
SOS !
Tu sais, il n'y a pas que du sale ici,
il y a aussi des gens qui souffrent,
des artistes inconnus.
Sans le savoir, du jour au lendemain,
on peut tous basculer dans la misère.
Les gens qui dorment dans une tente,
c'est parce qu'ils ont pas de maison,
mais ils restent des êtres humains quand même.
Je vous emmène aujourd’hui pour Brut
sur la colline du crack
où, depuis plus de 10 ans,
dealers et consommateurs de crack
se donnent rendez-vous.
Historiquement,
la colline du crack se trouve ici,
à Porte de la Chapelle,
au nord de Paris,
coincée entre les échangeurs de
l’autoroute A1 et le périphérique.
En novembre 2019,
le camp est évacué
et quelques semaines plus tard,
les 2000 habitants se réinstallent
juste 500 mètres plus loin
à Porte d’Aubervilliers.
Le lieu a une réputation violente
mais j’ai voulu vous raconter les parcours
et vous montrer les visages
de celles et ceux qui tentent d’y survivre.
Ça, c'est lourd !
Ça fait combien de temps que tu fais ça ?
Ça fait... ça fait longtemps !
Depuis la colline là-bas.
On est 3 ou 4.
On essaye toujours de faire le maximum.
Tu vois, on n'a pas de salaire
mais on le fait pour nous. Voilà.
Ça nous motive.
C'est du bon boulot mon frère !
Il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens comme toi !
Ça c'est une grande chose, tu sais.
C'est pas tout le monde qui a ce cœur-là,
de pouvoir nettoyer la saleté
de tout le monde ensemble, t'as vu.
C'est bon ?
Merci.
À quoi je sers ? Je ne sais pas…
Et ça, ça fait très, très mal.
Je suis bloquée pour mes papiers,
je suis bloquée pour plein de choses.
Je sors de prison.
J’ai pas un euro.
Je ne touche rien.
J’ai une addiction avec la drogue, l’alcool.
Des choses, que je croyais
qui allaient m'aider à oublier
et finalement ça m’a mis
plus de problèmes dans ma vie.
Maintenant, j’essaye de me maîtriser
grâce à Dieu.
Et ce que je cherche à faire,
c’est trouver un travail
mais dans le social. T'as vu ?
Quand les immigrés sont arrivés,
je leur ai montré là où il fallait
mettre leurs tentes, en-dessous du pont.
On leur a cédé la place.
Parce qu’on avait pitié et mal pour eux.
Et maintenant, eux-mêmes
ils commencent à devenir toxicomanes aussi,
parce qu’on les a envoyés
tout droit dans la merde.
Si c’est pour sortir de son pays
et devenir drogué comme ça, c’est malheureux.
Les migrants dont parle Mirlene,
ils ont été évacués
de tous les camps au nord de Paris.
C’est comme ça qu’il se sont retrouvés
ensuite sur la colline du crack.
T'as vu, avec la merde
que tout le monde fume,
les gens n'étaient pas comme ça avant.
C'est la drogue qui fait ça.
Je savais pas ce que c'était que le "crack".
J'avais jamais vu ça avant au bled.
On connaît pas, ça.
Alors que ça, ça tue !
Ça te détruit à l'intérieur.
Ça te mange de l'intérieur.
Et c'est à cause de cette merde-là,
que beaucoup de monde fait caca ici,
ils pissent juste à côté de là où on dort.
Les gens viennent et font l'amour sur ton lit !
Après, toi tu vas dormir,
tu attrapes des maladies,
la gale et toutes ces merdes-là.
À cause de quoi ?
À cause de cette putain de vie !
Qui peut nous sauver ?
Quel gouvernement peut nous sauver ?
Il faut construire un endroit
pour que les gens quittent ce lieu.
Moussa, je vais juste voir Booba,
s'il peut m'arranger
un petit truc à fumer, là, j'arrive.
On peut chuter.
On peut chuter sans le savoir,
du jour au lendemain,
on peut tous basculer dans la misère.
Les gens se voilent la face,
chez eux, ils se shootent
aux médicaments, à l'alcool,
les jeunes, ils se shootent
au shit, à la cocaïne...
C'est aussi des addictions,
c'est aussi de la drogue
et c'est pas pour autant
qu'ils arrivent pas à assurer à l'école,
au boulot ou dans leur vie de famille.
Eh ben on est pareils.
Le crack, en fait,
on l'appelle la drogue du pauvre.
C'est un dérivé très bas de gamme
de la cocaïne
mélangé avec du bicarbonate de soude
et de l'ammoniaque.
Sur la nouvelle colline,
j’ai rencontré Laurie,
une jeune Belge de 19 ans,
qui est devenue accro au crack très jeune.
Mais Aliou ! Réveille-toi, ouais !
Mais Aliou, regarde,
c'est tes cadeaux wesh !
J'ai chopé des vêtements sur le périph',
la vie de ma race je les ai volés, wesh.
Regarde !
C'est tout neuf, ouais !
Que mes parents m'en veulent pas
si ils me voient
parce que je leur avais dit
que j'avais arrêté de fumer.
Vu que je suis enceinte.
Ça te fait quel effet ?
Ben... ça me fait plus grand-chose.
Mimi !
Ça va ?
Après on va à l'association
pour se laver, hein ?
J'ai la flemme...
Je la connais depuis que j’ai 15 ans.
Ça fait 4 ans que je fume du crack
et à peu près 3 ans et demi que je suis là
mais de temps en temps
je retournais chez ma mère et tout,
mais là...
Là, je suis là 24/24h.
Laurie, c’est ma petite sœur, c’est ma fille.
Normalement, j’aimerais pas
qu’à mon âge elle se retrouve ici, encore.
T’as vu ?
Malheureusement, j’ai pas les moyens
de pouvoir agir comme il faudrait
pour ce genre de jeunes filles
qui gâchent leur vie ici.
Parce que tu sais, il n'y a pas que du sale ici,
il y a aussi des gens qui souffrent,
des artistes inconnus.
Des gens juste perdus, je crois,
qui cherchent juste à être retrouvés.
Ça, c'est mes dessins.
C'est le corps d'une femme.
Alors voilà,
mon histoire est assez longue,
triste et barbante.
Mon père,
pendant un week-end sur deux,
me tripotait de mes 2 ans
à mes 6 ans et demi.
De mes 6 ans et demi
à mes 7 ans et demi, c’était du viol.
Maman a porté plainte avec moi,
classé sans succès.
Ils m’ont placée 6 ans en centre
pédopsychiatrique car j’avais du mal.
Maman avait un nouvel homme,
un nouveau bébé et une nouvelle maison.
Génial.
Après, à 13 ans : fugue, traîner et dormir
avec des punks à chiens anarchistes
qui m’ont emmenée et fait goûter
le fameux crack à Porte de la Chapelle.
Moi, quand je fume, parfois,
je peux voir ma grand-mère.
Elle me supplie de ne pas aller
vers la lumière, d’où elle vient.
Pourquoi tu fais de la couture
à cette heure-ci ?
Parce que j'y pense pas.
Je pense qu'à fumer la journée.
Là, je pense à faire de l'argent pour fumer.
Si t'es du côté d’Aubervilliers, si t'as 50 balles,
eh ben on baise et on se voit, voilà.
C’est tout, y’a pas de longue histoire.
Il ne faut pas écrire 20 000 messages, c’est tout.
On baise, on ne baise pas.
T’as de l’argent, t’as pas d’argent. Bouge.
Oh, désolée hein, mais à un moment il faut être clair.
Regarde.
Ce serait mon rêve, la cabane idéale.
Je sais où je vais la mettre.
Tu vois il y a un arbre, là, c'est la porte.
J'aimerais bien, tu vois, avec l'arbre,
faire un étage où je mets le lit.
Tu veux faire ça où ?
Là-bas, plus loin, sur le périph'.
Malheureusement, l'histoire de Laurie,
c'est pas du tout une exception
sur la colline.
Les habitants de la colline
sont régulièrement expulsés
et ça ne fait que déplacer le problème.
En réalité, pour quitter le crack,
il faudrait pouvoir quitter la colline
mais beaucoup d'entre eux
n'ont nulle part où aller
et ici, c'est leur seule famille.
Souvent, si je me fais agresser,
ce sont les frères qui me défendent.
J'ai faim, j'ai rien.
Ce sont eux qui me défendent
parce que j'ai honte d'aller voir ma famille
pour leur dire que j'ai faim.
Il y a des gens qui s’aiment beaucoup ici.
Bien entendu que la misère les divise.
Mais il y a a encore de l’amour ici, bébé.
Fais-moi confiance.
Demande, demande,
demande, demande...
Demande, demande-leur.
Le temps passe et je change,
Les tribulations, on les a déjà vécues,
La fraternité, on l'a,
À présent on demande la...
solidarité.